so you've just met Troy and tyreme
calypso the calypso twins we learned
earlier that on Pandora there's a cult
called the children of the vault and
every cult needs leaders this cult is
led by the Calypso twins and they've
sort of built a cult of personality
around themselves right you guys know
the type of streamers we're talking
about you know the kind of streamers
everybody hates so these are like the
douchiest kind of streamers of the
impossible future that you can possibly
imagine
as tyring demonstrated she has the
ability to leech power from any living
thing and her aim is to use her cult to
lead her to the vaults so that she can
soak up the power of the vault monsters
of course we're vault hunters we can't
allow her to beat us to the prize so
with a vault map in hand we're now in a
race to find the vaults hidden on other
worlds throughout the galaxy in other
words when we go to those other worlds
we're gonna need a ride right so later
in our venture on Pandora we're gonna
find a spaceship
[Applause]
I'd like to introduce sanctuary 3 we
don't talk about sexual Ritu
since sanctuary 3 is our home base it's
a great stopping point between missions
on sanctuary 3 we can meet our friends
trade our loot and prepare ourselves for
what comes next you'll notice here
there's a quick-change station where we
can modify our appearance but there's a
new vending machine here on the right
this is sort of a space lost-and-found
if you guys ever lost loot in
Borderlands like a purple or a legendary
Lance in some place we can't reach we
collect all that loss for you a lost
loot and we'll deliver it here for you
you'll never lose loot again alright so
let's talk about this this is your
player quarters now because we're
playing Amara right now all of the
decoration everything is built around
tomorrow but you can see that you can
place items that you find in the world
like this gun all right we got a
tortoise ttle here for the rad but again
you can modify your player quarters to
how you want to play since we picked up
a pistol we'll take it with us on a tour
around sanctuary and why don't we stop
first let's head over to Marcus just
keep going to the door of that golden
chest
Marcus's place is right around the
corner here full of opportunity now
Borderlands 3 Marcus will be our vendor
for upgrades to our storage deck unit
right so we can get more storage to
carry more loot and more ammunition
you'll notice that it costs cash to
upgrade your storage -
Marcus also has a shooting range back
there so if you want to get your skills
up practice with any interesting new
guns you found you can do that we're
just gonna take a look around this place
in that cool this map has changed more
hands than any other content in
Borderlands 3 we've had so many of our
talented world builders want to give it
get their hands on this and make it
great it's not a hub until you have a
Moxie's bar right
my name's moxie what's yours sugar
thanks for the help sugar come back
let's try it yeah all right
well that's not good good luck well
thanks for encouraging that let's keep
going on the - all right
I love sanctuary I mean it's just such a
beautiful I don't know the level that I
didn't work on this one that much I just
kind of helped guide some of it but the
guys that worked but did the art for
this just it's absolutely stunning these
the jokes
knock-knock anyone home
[Music]
Oh Oh surprisingly comfortable you know
like fleshy sleeping bag although I do
feel a bit viscous so Tanis is back
but so let's go ahead up to the bridge
all right hey hey Paul yes Randy what
can we do on the bridge so for the first
time ever we can leave the Pandaren
system and you can see Pandora in there
in the distance
[ __ ] killer
all right let's get to it we're in orbit
around Pandora right now we'll check it
out briefly before we take off you can
see it's distinctive Veridian scar but
with a spaceship like sanctuary 3 we can
visit other worlds now this is early in
the game so we haven't unlocked a lot of
the other places that you will get to
explore but for now we're going to do
interstellar fast travel to Promethea
[Applause]
we're gonna go down to Promethean a
moment check it out we'll have to make
our way to the docking bay in order to
do that in Borderlands you'll be able to
go back and forth between Promethea and
Dora and all of the other worlds that
you discover throughout the game might
even find a few familiar faces here
what's up badass
[Applause]
I love Maya's look she's fully Jedi
doubt
we'll take a couple other stops on the
way down to the hangar before we had
that Promethea continue our tour of
sanctuary three
oh yeah let's go to hammerlock's now
here at hammerlock's one of the cool
things is hammerlock asks you to kill
different creatures and this is a trophy
room for killing those creatures it's
you apologies it's dark and I've never
actually cleaned this monocle you can
see right now all of the the trophy
mounts on the wall are empty which means
that we've got work to do a lot of work
do
and while you're in the ship you can see
we have shortcuts built-in the more time
you spend on Promethea the more familiar
you'll get with it we've kind of
engineered some shortcuts in other ways
to get around so you can finally you
need pretty quick your day going Ellie's
sort of our ship mechanic and she she
runs the cargo bag down here we can
check out vehicles we've collected we
can also get access to the planets when
we're in orbit we've also got some
stowaways we can meet what you out I
think is a vending machine there said
veteran on it
look at me like that I do it all the way
over here I don't and he locked us out
I think he's building a girlfriend I
can't believe that claptraps lonely it's
just hard to believe so we're gonna head
to the drop pod here this will help us
get down to Promethea in fact why don't
we just skip ahead a little bit rather
than start at the beginning of Promethea
we can jump forward a bunch of levels
and